so
my name is martha i'm a software
engineer at uber
which is a company in san francisco that
dispatches cabs and other vehicles to
your location
i work with javascript primarily so but
i do both client and server side
javascript but i also like python a lot
um but the title of my talk is the
javascript interpreter interpreted
but that's kind of a trick i'm not
really particularly interested in
interpreters
or compilers i'm really more interested
in how like the ecmascript specification
requires the interpreter to process your
javascript
um so um i like to remind myself of this
every once in a while software's primary
technical imperative
is does anyone know
any takers software's primary technical
imperative is
managing complexity and uh either
fortunately or unfortunately for us
javascript
is kind of complex it kind of deviates
from some of the paths well worn from
other languages
so in order to manage the complexity of
javascript i kind of like to dig into
the specifications and figure out
why things are complex or try and like
reduce the magic so that i actually
understand them
but i actually grabbed this little quote
from a book called code complete which i
highly recommend
it's by steve mcconnell uh so
javascript is usually interpreted but
not always
and in case you aren't familiar and when
something is interpreted it means that
your so
your source code which is your
javascript code is parsed
that is turned into an abstract syntax
tree uh that is generated into bytecode
and that is interpreted into machine
code which is just a
binary that runs on your machine so
note i say that javascript is usually
interpreted because
in javascript engines like v8 it's not
interpreted it's actually just converted
directly into machine code
um but like i said i'm not exactly
really interested in that i'm more
interested
in the mechanics of javascript itself
okay so the thing about javascript is
it's really wonderful
nearly everything is an object that
makes it incredibly flexible and
extensible
and even better i think is that
functions are first class objects
so that just means that functions can be
stored and referenced in a number of
ways
some of these or actually all of these
are functions can be stored inside
variables
they can be applied to objects as
methods they can be stored inside arrays
they can be passed as arguments to other
functions and they can be returned as
values from other functions
so considering that functions can do so
many things
i'd say to understand javascript it's
pretty imperative that you understand
how javascript itself creates and
executes function objects
in fact i'd say that everything about
your understanding of javascript hinges
on this
so the thing about function objects is
that they have two stages
uh they have a creation phase and an
execution space and they're distinct and
distinct things happen during each phase
so in the creation phase um this is when
your function has been invoked but not
yet executed
and during this phase a bunch of magic
happens which we'll go into more detail
um but within that magic scope is
determined and context is determined
and then um and during the execution
phase your function is just run
um so when a function object is created
it's
all dependent uh all the values that are
determined within
within that function are dependent on
the execution context
uh all javascript code that you write is
evaluated through an execution context
and basically uh lucky for us there are
only three of these
possible execution contexts that any of
our javascript code can be run through
the first one is global the second one
is function and the third is eval
and we're not really going to focus on
evol because it's not entirely practical
and um just as a little ranty side note
i don't think eval is inherently evil
it's just inherently dangerous
but regardless we're not really going to
talk about it
so whenever the browser first loads your
script it enters the global execution
context by default
and then from then on every time a
function is invoked it enters a function
execution context um
so and that actually also applies if a
function were to call itself recursively
each time then it calls itself a new
function execution context
is created um so execution context form
stacks
javascript in the browser is implemented
as a single thread and that means only
one thing can be executed at a time
so all the execution contacts are queued
so the first
execution context to be added to the
stack is the global
and then like i said each time that a
function is called its function
execution context is pushed to the top
of the stack
and when it finishes executing and it's
completed it is popped off the stack and
really
relinquishes control back to the one
below it
um so uh yeah and most of my examples
involve cats or girly things
deal with it uh so
uh what really is an execution context
if all of our code is evaluated through
it
really what is it uh i like to
conceptualize it as an object
it's not an actual object it doesn't
have a prototype it's not
immediately accessible in your code it's
just kind of like a construct of the
language but i like to visualize it as
an object
and basically it stores three things
that are relevant to the particular
context whether it be global or function
it contains something called a variable
object which
the variable object holds references to
all the arguments passed to the function
all the internal variables declared
within the function
and all of the functions declared
internally within that function
the scope chain is defined with an
execution context and basically it's
just a chain of objects that
are in scope for this particular context
but we will go into more detail
sorry that was vague and then the third
thing the execution context
contains is the value of this and the
value of this is
defined based on the context that this
function is being created and executed
in
and we will go into more detail about
that as well
so the first thing that i'd like to go
deeper
into is the variable object inside this
execution context
basically when your function is created
a variable object is created and within
it is a property
called arguments and it will hold a
reference to all the parameter names and
argument values
that are passed to this particular
function um so that's why
in your code you've realized that you
can access this argument's keyword
that's why because during variable
instantiation when your
object your function object is being
created this property is added
and available to the to the entire body
of your function
um so the next thing that happens is it
scans your code for all function
declarations and it takes the name or
the identifier of that function pulls it
up into this variable object
and then it sets the value to this a
pointer to the function object itself
so the third thing that it does is it
scans your code and finds all variable
identifiers
hoists them up into this variable object
and initially assigns them all as
undefined
that is critical uh so one thing to note
uh is if a function name exists already
uh the reference pointer value will be
overwritten
uh if a variable name exists already
when it's scanning uh the
variable or it will actually do nothing
and continue scanning because like
really what's the point it's just going
to define it as undefined anyways
okay so here's an example of hoisting
earlier when i said that
when variable identifiers are pulled up
into this variable object
they are initially assigned as undefined
that's because the actual definition or
the value that's assigned to that
variable does not
actually get applied to that variable
identifier until execution
so that means until the actual code has
processed the part of your program where
the equal sign assigns the value to the
variable name so
um the very top of my kitten function
i'm logging mu before i've actually
defined it so in the the function below
it i'm actually showing like
conceptually what the interpreter really
think or or what your what code
this what is actually happening behind
the scenes uh so
it's scanning your code it's finding the
variable mu pulling it up is undefined
your console logging at that point mu is
undefined
then in the next line mu is defined as a
string mu
at that point um you know the actual
value that you're anticipating is
assigned to the variable
um but another just interesting thing um
if you notice
uh it doesn't log like reference error
it's not saying this variable doesn't
exist anywhere it's just saying the
actual value of this variable is
undefined
and that's because of hoisting if you've
heard that term
and i really just wanted to drive this
home so i put this up as a slide
the properties created on the variable
object for local variable declarations
are initially designed
assigned as undefined
so the next thing i would like to talk
about is scope
um so despite javascripts you like
syntax javascript does not have block
level scoping
and that's because scope is only defined
at the function level or the global
level but more commonly we
interact with the function level so it's
not scope it does not exist in the
context of like an if block or a for
loop but only exists
when the function is created and that's
when it's assigned
uh so scope is actually a chain of
objects
um and what's interesting here is when
scope is defined when your
function object is being created the
first entry in this
chain of objects is the most immediate
variable object so all the variables and
function declarations
that were defined within this function
are
first and then it actually holds an
external link to its parents variable
object
which in turn the parent would hold a
link to its verb its parents variable
object
and this will just go all the way up
until you hit global so
that's why in any inner functions that
you have you can reference things stored
inside the global object because it
holds a reference
to this chain of scope that like
traverses all the way up to the global
object
but that's also why like a global object
could not reference anything inside of
an inner function it does not have that
ability and that's also why in
javascript globals are implicit
so identifiers identifiers are just
names of properties variables functions
and when i say resolved i just mean like
if inside of your function you're like
i want to find some kind of value with
the name of kitten
it's going to look up the scope chain
for all identifiers that
equal that same name of kitten and if it
doesn't find it in the most immediate
scope like in the most in its variable
object it will look up
the next level up into its parents
variable object if it doesn't find it
there it will continue looking for
upwards uh until you hit the global
object and if it doesn't find it then it
will just resolve as undefined
um and one thing to note is so
identifiers are
resolved against the scope chain but
this which is a key word is not
this is not an identifier this is a
keyword
so this uh holds a reference to the
object that the function is being
applied to
that's the simplest way i think to word
that um so
this does not necessarily mean that this
will equal the object where the function
is stored um okay so to go any further
uh if you're gonna understand my next
example
you need to go to youtube and look up b
and puppycat and this is like an anime
it's like a short it's like 10 minutes
long i'm entirely obsessed with it
um but so here i have a variable name b
i'm sending it equal to an object
with one property value of string b
doing the same thing for a variable
puppy cat setting it equal to an object
with one property name and its value is
puppycat
so on my first object i am applying or
i'm adding a method
and all it just does is return hi i'm
and then whatever the value of this
the whatever the property name is on
this at that point
so in the last line i'm doing something
like
wholly confusing but javascript lets you
do that
i'm creating a new property on my puppy
cat object and i'm setting it equal to
the method that i already defined on b
so what would this refer to
in this context the important thing to
remember is it's not where
the the actual keyword this is stored
it's stored in b
as a method on the b object right now
but actually
this corresponds to the object to which
it's applied
so right now it's actually applied
within the context of puppy cat not
within the context of b
um so whenever i'm like writing really
complicated javascript and i get a
little lost
uh i use these uh three points to kind
of guide me through
um if you're at a top level function if
it's not contained by any other function
this the value of this resolve to the
global window object
and there's actually a really
interesting reason why um the global
object
or when you're when your script is first
processed by the browser the global
object goes through variable
instantiation just like a function does
uh so that means all the top level
variables all the top level functions
actually are added as properties and
methods to the variable object of the
global object
so i know it sounds like crazy but
really if you're inside of a function
that is a top level function and you
reference
this keyword at that point it's
technically
like that function is technically a
method on the global object and so if if
my second point is correct where
if you're inside of a method the value
of this points to the object into which
it's applied
well then a top level function is
actually a method of the global object
so this points to that object
to which it is applied which is a global
object so sorry it's kind of confusing
um but then the third point is a
constructor um
if you have a constructor and it
generates objects the value of this
refers to each individual object not the
constructor itself
um so uh oh my god closures
uh this is often complicated or i know
it's kind of
it was very complicated to me when i was
first learning like programming or
javascript in general
and it doesn't have to be there's also a
lot of really terrible information on
the internet about what a closure is
but to put it as simply as i can a
closure is created when a function
remembers the variables and its scope
when it was created
so when a function is created it stores
an internal reference to the variable
object of itself and is
of its parent so technically anytime a
function is created a closure is formed
now whether you choose to actually
return that value or not is up to you
but returning the value
returning those variables that were in
scope when the function is created does
not
that's not what makes a closure
of course it's like probably way more
useful to return it
so this is a lot of text i'm so sorry
um but basically i'm just showing how
you can store something secretly within
a function
return other maybe methods that like
operate on that secret data but doesn't
actually reveal the secret data itself
so here i'm just kind of creating a
little game called find the kitten
you're guessing where it is
but the secret is actually like
obsecated from the from
the actual uh function once it's been
invoked like at that point it's just an
object you're just returning this object
with this like guess method
and really that's it um so yeah so the
the guess method is actually
able to operate on the secret because
it's within its variable
object it's within scope of that object
um
and that's how that you can actually
like play with the secret uh
whatever the secret variable within the
find the kitten function
so i blew through all my slides so
quickly i do this every time
but hopefully now you know more about
how javascript works i am so happy to
take questions
and i also have a challenge for you two
challenges
please follow me on twitter i really
like talking with people on twitter and
also if you can think of something
totally
like weird to endorse me for on linkedin
i will be forever grateful
um but yeah but i'm also questions or
find me afterwards
um or we could just all go get coffee
i'm fine with any of that yeah
when a closure is created does it
work or wrong i think it only references
variables that are used within that
function
not all variables
yeah that would definitely be more
concise yeah this was
i should have like totally had a some
kind of disclaimer that like all details
have been glossed over
all of them i was trying to like cover
as much like they
or someone like the pain points either i
felt or other people that i'm teaching
javascript have felt
um so yeah i would absolutely read the
specification if this is the kind of
thing you nerd out about
um yes
where all of the variable declarations
no matter where they are in
oh i did cover that yeah but when the
variable object is created
or when it yeah when your function is
created in the variable object
starting to define values within it it
scans all of your code and it takes all
the variable identifiers up into it as
properties but it assigns them all as
undefined
so yeah so it's that's essentially like
it pulling i guess like we're
conceptually like pulling all the
variable identifiers to the top of the
function
definition but really it's this variable
object that's just kind of like
available to like globally or locally
available to
your entire function but yeah totally um
it's weird
any other questions no no okay well
please come find me afterwards if you
would like to chat more
oh yes um do we have time
i don't have audio set up
you may have to come help me i am
helpless
this is your audio ah okay where's your
flick here
i don't actually know that it is on this
side
does it reach oh yeah
[Music]
i jaywalk but i can't we're getting a
ticket
no
change stupid white
a cat maybe a dog
huh
[Music]
girl good
i'm such a loser
oh my god that's my guts
[Music]
coming
hey hey nickard i heard you lost your
job
oh uh yeah too bad i can't make a career
out of getting fired right and be like a
ceo or a manager
which one's more impressive
are you gonna be okay oh my god
oh oh my god ah wait oh
i have
i got you uh ice for your crotch i'm
shoving the scratch ice under the door
oh you're awake wanna split a casserole
[Music]
ah hello well well
what ah wait
[Music]
where are you guys going
why does this make me feel so sad
[Music]
ah you were there a lasagna's gone
okay you have no documentable skills you
didn't
manage to finish schooling past high
school
work history spotty at best this is a
temp agency not a charity
hello uh-huh no well i didn't know that
he had a peanut allergy
okay well you know if it's just a little
bit of swelling then then just get them
away from the peanuts and and it'll be
over in about a half hour otherwise call
an ambulance
thank you yeah bye
you took too long now your candy's gone
that's what happened
[Music]
uh no thank you
[Laughter]
hey dude i got you presents
pet store i used to work at is going out
of business
lucky us so let me see
i got you a bone and wrapped a toy mouse
around it a blanket
eggplant pillow dog food cat food
shampoo a leash and rain boots
[Music]
yeah yeah
crap i ran out of food money
man i'm not gonna eat your food
stop no hitting there better not be
anything scary cryptic written here i
will scream
so loud and then totally lose my marbles
pretty stationary though
[Music]
dear puppy cat is that you
please report to fishbowl space for temp
work sign below
oh let me get you a pen
hello hello anybody here
i've been left behind i'm all
alone am i not
good enough
[Music]
you look different and hello
unrecognized intruder
unfortunately due to increased security
measures you must now be incinerated
[Music]
whoa
initiating uniform assignment
[Music]
i don't like this outfit please proceed
to fishbowl space
let me know when you're done
hi wallace
what's wrong i miss my mama
she's been gone forever
do you want something to drink no thank
you
you want a snack no you wanna
nap no he's
so sad
can i have a story
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then what that's your ending
that's awful and very interesting
i know it was you pretending it's just a
fairy tale
lying to children making him look up to
a hero
who in reality is just an awful
monster ah sick
foreign
okay why
what's that gonna do whatever
whoa jeez hey
was that story you told that fish true
oh did you forget how to talk again
oh my god i am so glad there wasn't
anything sharp on my couch
wow hey cat ash
whoa thank you and thanks for not
letting tempot burn me up
i think i'm gonna use my money to get
deckard a casserole
since he bought me a casserole what you
using your money for
oh ignoring me again fine
i liked your fairy tale puppy cat
if you want i can help you figure out a
nice ending
[Music]
yeah but that's what i'm obsessed with
so i'm really glad you got to experience
that with me